I stand here with great honor because we
called each other and I've been
with you been with you all for all all
your lives really and I stand here with
a great honor but uh so this is
for you with affection
my late mother-in-law used to say that
nothing can be said it can begin to take
away the anguish and the pain of these
moments because grief is the price we
pay for love
and how right she was and today we talk
about Lisa Marie we look at Priscilla as
a mother as a mother to Lisa Marie we
look to Lisa Marie and say you lost a
son
mothers losing children
it there are no words for it
so today we talk about action and action
is the way we can go forward we can
light the flame
so for Riley for Harper and Finley and
for the entire family
we March forward in support of you all
of us are with you and we will help you
as best you can if you just put out your
hand we will be there or well I will
definitely be there
so David Frost died and George Frost was
his son and I asked George if I could
read it today and it's for you
I've had my life and enjoyed every
second
but as it is another life has beckoned
it's important to know that I've not
gone
and I hope that on you all my light has
shone
stay in that sunshine
rest never in the shade
don't curse my absence
as this light you'll evade
I live in the smiles
the moon the stars and sky
and I feel Eternal Pride as I watch you
all fly
and for my darling children who wonder
what to do
just have a wonderful time
as I will living through you
thank you
foreign